schafft kann sein dass so etwas vergesse
ich das vergesse ich hab das jetzt oder
hatte jetzt hochzeitskleid gefahr
ich fühle man sich mal eingezogen
ach du mir selbst kann die platzwunde
28-jährige wie disney trage aber als 13
jähriger als cool gras das ist ein
moment habe protokoll muss und der
erfahrung
ich hab's vergessen
im lager habe ich das vergessen und das
jetzt wo ich es vergesse aber ich habe
nein reingepasst hast du noch nicht
jetzt kommen und das ist dann kann man
ein bild machen zusammen ja die jungs
heute hochzeitstag 13 jahre
hochzeitstag elf jahren wird er seinen
traum des bösen
und jeder ich habe ja dass man was durch
kurze zeit machen es auch mal nach es
stehen gestellt aber ich will das ja
wahnsinn
er ist ja das war nicht einfach aber ich
habe ja alles gute zur hochzeit sagt ja
auf weitere 13 jahre elf jahre lieb von
dir ja deshalb in der partie gegen eine
wolke gelungen habe ich geholt habe
bonn ddp
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das immer besser
ja
ja wer fliegt raus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hätte man alles jetzt nicht ganz so
thomas letzten thomas gewöhnt dass er
jetzt heiratet wahnsinn hier dein
strauss-kahn hier gebe ich auch arbeiten
männer und ziehen daraus den fragt wo
mein anzug ist naja ist passt nicht mehr
er passt doch noch das bein über ein
weil wir alles gut sagt mach weiter so